so the first trailer foot hello my baby
hello my honey hello my ragtime gal yes
the first shoulder for alien covenant is
out and oh god all right look first a
little bit of background I was actually
kind of excited about this movie
thinking on it now I'm not entirely sure
why but I'm going to be coming out with
my top anticipated movies of 2017 soon
that was on the list and you know what
right now I got an empty space to fill
you got to see if there's anything else
i want to put there cuz it's not on the
list now now I guess before I get too
much into this a little bit of
background with me I love the Alien
franchise all of the first one I love
aliens I think alien 3 is good if it
would have been very good if not for
that initial sin of killing Hickson new
which really does taint the whole thing
the fourth and movies kind of a
fascinating failure actually I'm even
kind of a sucker for alien vs predator
but when it comes to prometheus which
was the immediate predecessor to this I
actually think better on it than a lot
of people it is a deeply flawed movie on
a very fundamental level but I think it
had a lot of potential I have a lot of
really good ideas and I was looking
forward to the sequel because I liked
where it left off I mean it leaves with
Noomi Rapace his character with a head
of an Android and toe going off to find
and confront the creators of the human
race think about that for a second
that's Roy baddies story from Blade
Runner yes I want that now I love Ridley
Scott I think he is a brilliant director
but he really needs good material to
work with that unfortunately he doesn't
always seem to have a great sense of
what is good material but we know he can
still direct great movies he directed
the marsh and only a couple years ago
which was brilliant but my concerns
first want to put the name change
because this originally was of course
going to be prometheus 2 and now it's
being made as alien covenant now when
that first happened I got a little bit
concerned not only because it appeared
to bump Neill Blomkamp's in process
alien 5 that was being worked on but
also just because that made it sound
like they were
a distance it from prometheus and I
don't like that like I said there's a
lot of problems with Prometheus and I'm
not going to argue that there aren't but
where it left off the world that it
built I wanted to see the next step in
that story now this trailer comes out
there is no sign of numerous anywhere
and we see Michael Fassbender but he's
got a head attached which to me says
it's probably just another version of
the David Android so in my mind if we
get those characters in this movie and
all they're probably going to pull a
Luke in the force awakens where they get
talked about for a while and maybe show
up at the very end and that's not what I
wanted their story because if you're not
going to tell their story all that you
can do is do what every sequel since
aliens has done which is to retread the
same thing now aliens was the only one
that got away with it because it shifted
genres from horror to action and it made
it bigger and it gave us it gave us more
to explore now Prometheus tried to give
us more to explore it hit dad didn't
quite get there a followed to prometheus
could have continued to expand that
world and given us the bigger version of
what Prometheus gave us do the up being
in the way the aliens up from alien they
did seem to just be going back to and we
made a horror slasher movie in space now
i'm not against a horror slasher movie
in space i'd love a good horror slasher
movie in space but alien is the default
definitive slasher movie in space and i
don't need another one like there was
nothing about this that clicked for me
it's just the whole thing red generic
and blank I mean there are a couple of
like little tiny moments that were like
okay that looks fine but again it
doesn't look any better or any more
original than anything else the entire
franchise has already done I just came
away feeling and I tweeted this out if
you follow me on twitter at council of
geeks that i said i came away just
thinking this is a waste of so many
talented people's time it's a waste of
ridley scott's time the guys getting up
there in age he needs to be focusing on
better projects than this it's a waste
of michael fassbender's time it's a
waste of great production design and
great cinematography because it's a good
looks good but it's a good looking thing
we've seen and not only like seen once
before but we've seen repeatedly many
times at this point and that just leaves
me with feelings gonna be ways to help
our time
as audience members I mean I don't know
what else there is to say at this point
I mean you probably wouldn't bug me if I
didn't know that Ridley Scott was the
one directed it's like I said he's
better than this if all they wanted to
do was retread alien again they could
have gotten any number of journeyman
directors of hack directors of
up-and-coming directors to do this you
don't need to be wasting Ridley Scott's
time with this junk and here's another
thing I'm concerned Prometheus as not
great as it was had a brilliant
marketing and fantastic crews and they
got you pumped so if that not so great
movie they could sell so well and this
they can't even sell it decently yeah
that doesn't that doesn't feel like a
positive equation but in any case you've
seen this trailer yet odds are you have
what do you think about it whatever your
thoughts were drop something down in the
comments and let's talk about it don't
forget to Like subscribe check me out on
Twitter at Council of geeks check out
the Council of geeks podcasts available
on iTunes and stitcher I'm until next
time this council is adjourned